la guerra arremete nuevamente contra el
periodismo el sábado Se confirmó el
asesinato de un fotógrafo ucraniano su
cuerpo fue encontrado al norte de la
capital maxim levin trabajaba para un
medio ucraniano y era colaborador de
routers entre otros medios
internacionales el periodista Había
decidido ir al pueblo de mochón donde
hubo fuertes de enfrentamientos este
asesinatos se suma a la lista de nombres
de periodistas que han muerto en terreno
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa
brent renaud fue el primero donde su
colega Juan Arredondo ciudadano Colombo
estadounidense resultó herido
cruzamos el primer puente en irpin y
vamos a filmar a refugiados que se iban
nos subimos a un auto
alguien se ofreció a llevarnos al otro
puente y cruzamos el control donde
empezaron a disparar
reporteros Sin fronteras ha informado
que desde que empezó la guerra dos
periodistas ucranianos han muerto y tres
extranjeros en el terreno los
periodistas expresan sentirse amenazados
todo el tiempo que hubo momentos en los
cuales de mi vida corría peligro pero
creo que esto es la normalidad para
todos los colegas que en este momento
están informando sobre Ucrania en el
terreno hay bombardeos hay explosiones
hay disparos eso que hemos contado
nosotros lo hemos visto con nuestros
ojos las autoridades ucranianas han
informado que los asesinatos se han dado
a causa de los ataques rusos sin embargo
es información no se ha confirmado hasta
el momento por otras fuentes mientras
organizaciones de derechos humanos han
exigido a ambas naciones garantizar la
seguridad de los periodistas en medio de
la guerra